[Music]
one two three four five six seven eight
spots on my face too much acne to
embrace the person behind them sits on
my back with heads bright white scarlet
and blank in much too much an awkward
place to pull them pimples on my chest
probably there because I'm stressed
about the people talking behind my back
about the spots on my face but once I
wish I could erase just like so-called
friends that liked to tease me about
them
Clearasil and freedom sitting in my
bathroom the spots on my face can
confirm that they don't really work
Proactiv Solution deserves an execution
for being and completion that does
nothing but smirk at me because I'm an
acne aunty
[Music]
one two three four five six seven eight
countless times I've tried and tried but
my skin just sends I'm all dried and I
am left wanting to stay inside but then
one day I said Charlie it's not as bad
as it could be the early spots it's not
like you died
be a man the hell you are the try not to
walk them in case they scar
even though squeezing them is fun fun
fun understand at the end of the day to
put your hands down to say okay get out
of the bathroom and lie out in the Sun
because I heard that that helps clear a
cell and freedom sitting in my bathroom
the spots on my face can confirm the
data really your work Proactiv Solution
deserves an execution for being an
illusion that does nothing but smirk at
me cuz I'm an acne routine but I won't
let that define me because the people
that mind don't matter and the people
that matter don't mind so when all that
huskeroos splatter you will wipe it from
your marrow and wipe it from your mind
you could try a dairy-free diet and
drink 8 cups of water a day but in the
end your acne will still run right cuz
the hormones that cause them just won't
go away
[Music]
Clara so and freedom sitting in my
bathroom sports or my bitch can coupon
that they don't really work Proactiv
Solution
deserves an extra controller for peak
and a pollution that does nothing but
smirk at me cuz I'm an acne ridden
somewhat smelly kind of weird but
generally a okay teen house alright go
that one you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool